[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre 7 8 dans
l'actualité de ce mercredi 6 septembre
de la politique hier
Othman Nasro a lancé officiellement sa
campagne à La Celle-Saint-Cloud pour
devenir le futur président du parti les
républicains dans les Yvelines le
vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France est conseillé municipal
d'opposition de Trappes souhaite
redynamiser le mouvement de droite les
précisions dans ce 7 8
21,5 millions c'est le nombre de
touristes qui ont choisi de visiter la
région
Île-de-France durant les 6 premiers mois
de l'année 2023 une fréquentation en
hausse qui atteint presque les chiffres
d'avant covid-19 robe blanche gâteau
fleur ou encore bijoux tout était réuni
le week-end dernier lors du premier
grand salon du mariage organisé dans le
sud du département
avec environ 5000 mariages par an le 78
est de plus en plus prisé par les mariés
ont fait le point et puis l'invité du 7
8 en deuxième partie d'émission on va
parler sport avec Thomas chardon le
nouveau président du Football Club de
Poissy la structure a remplacé laisse
Poissy qui était en difficulté
financière
merci d'être là merci d'y croire encore
moi je crois l'avenir de la droite je ne
crois d'ailleurs à l'avenir que de la
droite pour notre pays redynamiser la
droite dans les Yvelines et au niveau
national c'est la priorité d'Othman
Nasro le vice-président de la Région
Île-de-France et premier secrétaire
général délégués des républicains se
présente pour la présidence à la
Fédération yvelinoise DLR son premier
souhait que le parti regagne du terrain
dans le département nous allons avoir
des élections sénatoriales et il est
extrêmement important dans ces élections
que l'on donne la majorité la plus large
possible et bien à nos sénateurs et aux
présidents du Sénat parce que le Sénat
est aujourd'hui un pôle de stabilité
majeur quand on voit l'état de
l'Assemblée nationale deuxième objectif
rajeunir le parti et faire émerger des
talents hautement Nasro a déjà fait
appel à de nouveaux membres dans son
équipe aujourd'hui le parti est
vieillissant et je pense que c'est sa
jeunesse les nouvelles méthodes en fait
qu'il faut utiliser pour redynamiser le
parti et faire un renouveau dans cette
salle de la selle Saint-Cloud ils
étaient plus de 80 militants à venir
soutenir le candidat je connais déjà
Hotmail c'est quelqu'un de merveilleux
qui a le sens du travail qui
effectivement dans les Yvelines je peux
vous dire qu'il va se battre on aura
beaucoup de monde derrière lui
d'ailleurs il est très charismatique
très apprécié et beaucoup de jeunes
maintenant viennent auprès de lui je
sais que c'est quelqu'un de brillant
d'intelligent et qui va pouvoir
insuffler un nouveau souffle à notre
fédération pour le moment aucun autre
candidat n'est connu pour cette élection
ce scrutin interne devrait se tenir
cours en novembre
ce n'est pas encore les niveaux du
tourisme d'avant covid mais ça s'y
rapproche entre janvier et juin dernier
l'Île-de-France a accueilli 21,5
millions de visiteurs une augmentation
de 17% par rapport au premier semestre
2022 la dynamique est confirmée par les
nuits des hôtelières également en forte
progression au total les touristes ont
généré 9,5 milliards d'euros de
retombées économiques pour la région
c'est une clientèle qualitative c'est
une clientèle qui consomme c'est une
clientèle
j'allais dire voilà celle que nous
voulons c'est à dire de du tourisme du
tourisme qui n'est pas du sur tourisme
qui n'est pas du tourisme low cost qui
n'est pas du tourisme Tchip qui qui
serait qui risquerait d'abîmer nos sites
ou qui risquerait de déplaire j'allais
dire aux habitants et de et de les gêner
la clientèle internationale revient
aussi en nombre en Île-de-France cet été
à la représenté plus de la moitié des
touristes accueillis dans la région une
saison estivale qui a été également
dispositive malgré une météo parfois
morose il a pas fait si mauvais que ça
en Île-de-France je dirais pas qu'il y a
un micro climat mais non on a eu quand
même des semaines de beau temps et puis
on a eu des semaines de temps qui sont
tout à fait convenables quand on vient
visiter une ville parce qu'en réalité
quand on devait visiter une ville on
veut surtout voir des monuments etc donc
un temps un temps de printemps n'est pas
forcément au contraire
dissuasif pour un tourisme urbain c'est
plus dissuasif évidemment pour un
tourisme balnéaire ou de montagne et des
perspectives sont bonnes pour les
prochains mois en vue de la Coupe du
monde de rugby qui se tient en France la
région s'attend à recevoir 450
000 supporters étrangers en majorité il
viendront de la Grande-Bretagne de
l'Argentine ou encore de la
Nouvelle-Zélande
dans le reste de l'actualité un
adolescent retrouvé pendu dans sa
chambre hier à Poissy le jeune de 15 ans
est décédé malgré l'intervention des
pompiers au domicile familial dans le
quartier de La Maladrerie selon nos
confrères du Parisien les enquêteurs du
commissariat de Conflans Honorine
privilégie la thèse du suicide en lien
avec des faits de harcèlement scolaire
dont a été victime le garçon dans son
ancien lycée Adrienne Bolland à Poissy
il avait signalé ses faits avec son père
il y a quelques mois au commissariat de
police de la ville l'adolescent avait
été rescolarisé dans un lycée de Paris à
la rentrée
les Jeux Olympiques à Paris est dans les
Yvelines c'est dans 324 jours cette
semaine le comité d'organisation reçoit
les médias du monde entier pour les
préparer à l'événement où vont
travailler 4000 journalistes et 1500
photographes au programme notamment de
cette semaine la visite des différents
sites des JO c'est ici aux alentours de
13h que 400 à journalistes
internationaux sont arrivés ici dans les
Yvelines au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour découvrir
les lieux qui m'ont accueillir les
épreuves de cyclisme sur pistes lors des
Jeux olympiques de Paris à 2024 ils se
sont ensuite rendus du côté du Stadium
de BMX un lieu qui va accueillir les
épreuves de BMX Race ensuite tout le
monde a embarqué pour rejoindre le
château de Versailles un lieu qui va
accueillir à la fois les épreuves
d'équitation et de pentathlon moderne
ils se sont ensuite tous rendus à Paris
pour visiter à les sites parisiens qui
vont accueillir à les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques en 2024 IR les
journalistes ont participé à une journée
à briefing dans un hôtel parisien ils
ont pu poser toutes leurs questions
concernant leur accréditation ou encore
le matériel qu'ils pourront utiliser sur
place au total 4000 journalistes seront
accrédité à pour l'événement et ils
viendront du monde entier et à quelques
jours des traditionnelles forum des
associations Voisins-le-Bretonneux lance
cette initiative à 100 minutes le
principe dédié environ une minute de
vidéo associations pour qu'elles
puissent se faire connaître et être
valorisé ses capsules sont ensuite
diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux et le
site Internet de la Ville l'ensemble des
140 associations vicinoises peu en
bénéficier il suffit de prendre contact
avec la mairie
[Musique]
musique romantique et défilé de robe de
mariée pour la première fois
particuliers spécialiste se sont réunis
pour échanger à l'occasion du premier
grand salon du mariage un événement
inédit pour le département c'est parti
d'un constat l'Insee annonce 50% de la
population mariée sur le 78 on regarde
beaucoup de lieux de prestige beaucoup
de prestataires et pas de salon du
mariage c'est les prestataires
connaissent le territoire ensuite c'est
tellement plus facile d'échanger avec
son prestataire quand il est pas très
loin et enfin
le fait de pouvoir prendre le temps
parce que c'est cocooning c'est c'est
pas une usine c'est pas une usine bien
que celui de l'année prochaine que je
auquel je pense déjà sera plus grand
mais malgré tout il restera esprit
cocooning il y en a pour tous les goûts
tenu de cérémonie sur mesure pièce
montée traiteur et même faire par
styliser l'objectif du salon est clair
centraliser et simplifier l'organisation
du mariage
le lieu d'accueil de l'événement n'a pas
été choisi au hasard selon l'Insee près
de 5000 mariages par an ont été célébrés
dans le département une aubaine pour
cette créatrice
de châteaux et de lieu de réception pour
les mariages et pour les grands
événements c'est important d'être
visible surtout dans ce département-là
plus accessible que les salons parisiens
trouvaient son bonheur ici et plus
simple les futurs mariés à la recherche
de conseils ont de quoi faire de cette
fête un moment inoubliable on a en plein
préparatif pour notre mariage j'ai ma
future femme du coup Morgan qui m'avait
dit qu'il y avait un événement juste à
côté chez nous à 5 km donc on s'est dit
que c'était l'occasion en fait de passer
pour voir un peu ce qui était proposé
notamment au niveau des robes de mariée
pour le costume de Mario 6 au niveau des
tenues pour le voyage de noces les
services pour les bars tout ce qui va
avec le salon a tiré environ 300
visiteurs eux aussi vont peut-être
succomber au charme des Yvelines pour
célébrer leur mariage comme l'ont fait
par le passé Brigitte Bardot à
Louveciennes ou Jamel Debbouze à cerner
la ville
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous présenter collatéral
de Michael man donc c'est un film de
2004 écrit par Betty Michael Manon on
connaît beaucoup et on parle beaucoup de
son film culte it avec Robert De Niro et
Al Pacino et du coup latéral est pas
dire qu'on sait comme un de ces films
peut-être moins important ça fait mon
graphique et en tout cas moi des films
que je préfère on suit l'histoire d'un
d'un chauffeur de taxi Max qui prend en
stop Vincent joué par Tom Cruise et qui
est au cours d'une nuit en fait de façon
à teinture un gage et qui a cinq carrés
à faire et 5 contrats à réaliser c'est
un des premiers films après Star Wars
épisode 2 à utiliser une caméra
numérique pour quasiment intégrater
l'intégralité du tournage ce qui
aujourd'hui voilà coulerait de sourge à
dire mais en tout cas à l'époque c'était
pas le cas et notamment parce que
Michael man voulait rendre la ville Los
Angeles dans laquelle se déroule le film
voulait vous les montrer la vie comme un
vrai personnage à part entière avec des
caméras avec en tout cas si le film
avait été tourné en pellicule
n'aurait pas eu la profondeur de champ
que qui souhaitait on n'aurait pas vu la
skyline au soins au loin on n'aurait pas
du tout ces lumières de la nuit mais
cette ambiance très granuleuse du film
et du coup le numérique a permis ça donc
malgré la terre des pionniers et des
premiers plâtres parce que c'était pas
les mêmes caméras numériques à l'époque
on disait aujourd'hui et voilà c'est un
film avec Tom Cruise à contre emploi qui
est absolument incroyable dans ce rôle
de tueur à Garges froid méthodique on
l'attend pas et pour moi des meilleurs
rôles de Tom Cruise et voilà une vraie
réflexion sur sur notre humanité
aujourd'hui sur notre alimentation et
sur notre isolement dans les dans les
grandes villes modernes et un film voilà
qui se passe en une nuit une virée
nocturne et que je vous recommande
fortement
[Musique]
il y a eu beaucoup de changements du
côté de Poissy au niveau du football cet
été pour nous parler de tous ces
changements je suis avec le nouveau
président du Poissy Football Club Thomas
chardon bonjour bonjour Michael alors
expliquez-nous un peu ce qui s'est passé
cet été
c'était la course ça a été un défi un
défi extraordinaire qu'on m'a qu'on m'a
donné
du coup il y a eu les premières
sanctions qui sont tombées envers les
poissons à partir du mois de mai par la
DNCG qui est excluait le club de toutes
les compétitions nationales
la mairie par l'intermédiaire du maire
madame de Santos a décidé de mettre
de maintenir la confiance envers
l'ancienne équipe qui dirigeait les
Poissy et lui a laissé une chance de
s'en sortir
ça n'a pas fonctionné et donc le 4
juillet le jour où les sanctions étaient
confirmés charges m'a été donné de
monter de nouvelles structure
associative qui permettent au football
de continuer à Poissy donc ensuite avec
mon équipe on s'est mis en ordre de
marche et depuis le 7 juillet on a on a
tout fait on a on a créé une nouvelle
association on a fait les démarches
auprès de la Ligue auprès de la fédé
auprès du district pour inscrire tous
nos équipes et pour faire en sorte que
que les que le football continue que les
niveaux se maintiennent donc aujourd'hui
on a eu la confirmation et l'opportunité
de maintenir les niveaux chez les filles
l'ensemble des catégories chez les
filles seniors aux jeunes et chez nos
équipes de jeunes donc c'est déjà une
première victoire aujourd'hui la seule
incertitude qui reste ça concerne le
football masculin chez les seniors nos
trois équipes seigneurs garçons et il a
eu 20 mais voilà donc un nouveau projet
de nouvelles personnes de nouvelles
perspectives et une envie majuscule pour
nous pour synthétiser pour les
téléspectateurs lace aussi avait un trou
d'un peu plus de 200000 euros dans les
caisses si je me trompe pas c'est c'est
ça qui a fait que la s.i on va dire est
mort et que le Poissy Football Club est
né le la disparition de l'expression en
fait je pense résulte de de tout à ta
facteurs moi je suis pas très à l'aise
pour parler de la fin de lait Poissy
parce que j'ai pu le dire précédemment
j'imagine que ça a été une souffrance
énorme pour le président pour l'ensemble
de ces équipes les lycée vésic parce que
pour essayer d’un club historique né en
1904 et voilà malgré tout eux ils sont
c'est un peu le point final de l'as
passé donc j'ai pas m'étaler aujourd'hui
il y a une dette colossale je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé le résultat sont là
le club le club a déposé le bilan la
liquidation judiciaire a été a été
prononcé le 4 août place maintenant au
principe Football Club et
je m'absiendrai de tout commentaire sur
sur la gestion passée pour pour les
laisser tranquille maintenant que c'est
fini on va revenir au présent qu'est-ce
qui vous a motivé vous personnellement à
devenir président de cette nouvelle
structure
je crois que ça s'arrête moins un rêve
que j'ai depuis que je suis tout petit
depuis que j'ai fait le deuil d'être
footballeur professionnel n'ayant pas
les compétences pour pour être
footballeur je m'étais toujours dit
imagine si un jour le club t'appartient
et que tu peux mettre en place ce dont
tu penses le meilleur pour le pour les
jeunes et pour le club en particulier
moi j'étais joueur de poussins jusqu'à
mes 17 ans j'étais vice-présor du club
de 2015 à 2017 donc j'ai déjà une une
petite vision mais j'ai jamais vraiment
été décisionnaire sur sur le club alors
quand même le maire m'a appelé pour me
dire est-ce que tu serais intéressé le
challenge et important est-ce que tu es
prêt à le relever j'ai pas hésité et ça
a correspond un petit peu à mon état
d'esprit de manière globale je suis en
impulsif quand ça me plaît quand je sens
que c'est le moment je fonce et puis et
puis on verra après ça fonctionne mais
je voulais pas laisser passer le train
et vous étiez un fan vous de la spoicie
de de l'équipe de Poissy moi je suis
nappe aussi j'ai vécu 30 ans à Poissy
j'en ai 37 aujourd'hui
donc ouais j'ai toujours beaucoup aimé
ce club et et j'ai jamais imaginé
réussir à obtenir ce poste la moyenne
donc quand la chance m'a été proposée je
pouvais pas dire non donc donc c'est
plus les poissons Football Club mais le
club continue enfin le football continue
à Poissy et nous on va essayer de
maintenir maintenir ce niveau là faire
en sorte que Poissy redevienne un club
important au niveau régional que soit
chez les jeunes chez les filles et chez
les grands avant de penser à d'autres
objectifs qui pour l'instant n'ont pas
lieu d'être exprimé on est trop loin
pour exprimer à des objectifs à plus
importants oui on sent quand même que
vous êtes ambitieux quand même dans
votre discours vous avez envie de bien
faire
si j'avais pas un minimum d'ambition je
crois que j'aurais pas accepté de
challenge parce que parce que sans
ambition n'aurait pas réussi en un mois
et demi à mettre le club sur pied avec
avec toute l'équipe quand tu es un livre
qui est mon directeur général Gary
Fournier qui est mon directeur sportif
l'ensemble du CODIR avec qui on bosse on
est on est 7 dans ce comité directeur
cette profil complètement différent mais
il y a de la jeunesse il y a de la
compétence il y a de l'envie et c'est
que des personnes de la société civile
personne m'a été imposé par la
municipalité et c'est d'ailleurs une des
conditions ce n'est la plus importante
que j'ai donnée quand j'ai accepté de
prendre le dossier c'est pas d'ingérence
moi dans ma vie professionnelle je suis
gérant d'une librairie indépendante
aussi à Poissy je tiens beaucoup à mon
indépendance et j'aurais pas accepté
qu'on m'impose à un moment donné
quelqu'un donc voilà l'ambition dès le
départ elle était là de remettre sur
pied un club après
je suis compétiteur l'équipe que j'ai
mise en place on est tous des
compétiteurs et on a tous dans un coin
de notre tête l'idée
de retrouver à court moyen terme un
niveau un peu plus conforme à ce que
peut être ce qu'on peut attendre d'un
club comme Poissy une ville comme Poissy
donc ça prend du temps mais on a plein
d'idées on est motivé on a on a mis en
place une équipe assez large pour pour
répondre à cette
urgence de résultats mais
ouais on est il y a beaucoup de
motivation beaucoup beaucoup d'envies
Quentin olive qui a été joué ici à
Poissy il va apporter aussi son
expérience aussi de ce club moi j'ai
pris Quentin pour plein de raisons la
première c'est que je le connais depuis
assez longtemps maintenant ça a été un
de mes stagiaires dans ma précédente vie
avant la librairie donc c'est quelqu'un
que je suis depuis plus de 10 ans c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement compétent c'est
quelqu'un qui j'ai une extrême confiance
qui a été diplômée de grandes écoles
notamment l'école du Real Madrid sur le
management du sport c'est quelqu'un qui
a une carrière de footballeur
professionnel aux États-Unis en Bulgarie
au Luxembourg il connaît la esprit aussi
parce qu'il a été joueur donc il a
spanniel comme ça de connaissances et de
culture au niveau du football il a
l'envie il a les épaules relever le
challenge aussi parce que c'est pas
c'est pas facile lui dire il est au
Luxembourg et gagner sa bien sa vie
viens à Poissy tu attends prendre plein
la tronche parce qu'en plus de ça tu es
le fils du député et puis les gens vont
naisser en faire l'amalgame à un moment
donné car le livre sur sur ton nom alors
que alors que quand tu es olive n'est
pas car le livre quand olive est un
homme de 27 ans mature et en qui j'ai
une énorme confiance et pour qu'un duo
fonctionne bien il faut que cette
confiance là il a confiance en moi j'ai
confiance en lui et je lui donne les
clés du camion sans aucun souci au
niveau des licenciés on tournait aux
alentours du 800 licenciés à l'aise
Poissy la saison dernière vous pensez
avoir combien de licencié à la rentrée
c'est aujourd'hui compliqué à estimer
on serait tous très heureux si on peut
avoir 600 licenciés à la fin du mois de
septembre voilà si on peut partir sur
sur 600 licenciés pardon ce serait ce
serait très bien comment on l'explique
on l'explique par une vague de départ
assez importante dans tout le temps
d'incertitude qui a qui était entre la
création du poisson Football Club et
puis la disparition effectivement de
l'est aussi au nombreux joueurs qui
évoluent un niveau régional ou au niveau
national avec la N2 non pas voulu
attendre n'ont pas pu attendre que le
que la suite soit connu donc ils sont
partis on a une centaine de départ
volontaires
et donc voilà après il peut y avoir des
surprises on peut peut-être récupérer
ces jours là mais sous d'autres sous
d'autres formes donc une ambition de
base cette année sur sur le nombre de
licenciés on peut avoir que des bonnes
surprises et puis et puis voilà on va on
statue sur une 600 licenciés on verra si
on fait mieux de quelle catégorie à
quelle catégorie des tout petits à
partir de 6 ans jusqu'au jusqu'au
jusqu'au vétéran donc on embrasse toutes
toutes les classes d'âge on refuse
personne tous les PCs sont les bienvenus
donc
on refuse personne et toutes les
catégories sont représentées au Plessis
Football Club j'imagine qu'il y aura un
forum des associations dans quelques
jours à Poissy on se reforme des
associations le 10 septembre on sera là
du début jusqu'à la fin et puis et puis
on pourra répondre à toutes les
questions des parents et toutes celles
et ceux qui ont vu pas mal de choses
circulaient cet été sans avoir aucune
réponse parce qu'en plus de ça pour
l'instant on n'a pas de locaux de locaux
donc on espère aussi bientôt en
récupérer pour être au plus près de nos
licenciés pour répondre à toutes les
questions oui comment ça va se répartir
aussi au niveau des des terrains on
garde les mêmes terrains que l'AS Poissy
on garde exactement la même organisation
donc on sera et sur le Cosec et sur le
Lagrange nos bureaux on se rendait à Léo
Lagrange pour l'administratif on aurait
une vraie vie club aussi on aura un
secrétaire qui sera à tous les
après-midi on va essayer de redonner un
petit peu de de sens à ce que peut être
un club de football associatif voilà
donc c'est pas uniquement l'entraînement
il va y avoir d'autres choses qu'on va
essayer de mettre en place pour montrer
que voilà il y a l'excellence sportive
on est là pour faire en sorte que les
jeunes et les moins jeunes jouent au
football et prennent ils prennent du
plaisir mais je crois qu'on a un rôle
supplémentaires aussi quand on quand
elle passe au Football Club et quand on
a 600 licenciés c'est d'accompagner les
jeunes qui viennent qui nous rejoignent
sur d'autres sujets moi j'aimerais bien
associer la l'excellence sportive à
l'excellence sociale on va notamment
développer la dose pour les petits qui
pas forcément les moyens à la maison
d'avoir de l'aide quand ils rentrent
donc de quoi devenu une recette plutôt
de faire leurs devoirs avec des
enseignants diplômés ou à la retraite
qui peuvent les accompagner donc voilà
essayez de redonner aussi un sens
associatif à au club on va maintenant
parler de l'équipe senior masculine
l'équipe fanion de chaque club de
football qu'en est-il de cette équipe
seniors masculine qui évolué la saison
dernière en National 2 et qui va chuter
de quelques divisions aujourd'hui la
décision n'a pas été encore statué
définitivement par la Ligue de football
de Paris a priori on devrait redémarrer
en R3 qui est le plus bas niveau
régional
mais ce qui serait pour nous à moindre
mal donc on attend encore cette décision
là
de très bons espoirs qu'on redémarrer R3
quant à nos seniors féminines le la
gestion est actée on redémarra bien en
R1 donc au quatrième niveau national et
c'est une une catégorie dans lequel on a
on a beaucoup d'espoir on va tenter de
dynamiser aussi parce que le football
féminin ne prend plus d'importance et le
football féminin à Poissy et très très
bien structuré autour d'Ibrahima Traoré
notamment qui fait un boulot formidable
avec tous ces équipes donc ça on va
tâcher aussi de le développer encore
plus pour l'équipe seniors masculine une
descente en District ça serait vraiment
compliqué à gérer ça serait compliqué
parce que parce que j'arrive pas à
concevoir un club de football en
séparant les blocs les jeunes d'un côté
les filles au milieu et puis les garçons
seniors dans leur coin pour moi ce club
est doit être uni et si on a l'équipe
fanion garçon qui retombe en
départemental et ben on va démarrer
encore plus loin pour attirer des
joueurs c'est encore plus compliqué pour
attirer les sponsors être plus compliqué
pour la dynamique qu'on essaie de mettre
en place être aussi compliqué
après on part de zéro on a créé un club
en un mois et demi donc je vais vous
dire c'est pas ça qui va nous arrêter on
va continuer on prendra la on prendra la
sanction comme elle comme elle doit être
prise mais
j'en appelle à la clémence et puis et
puis voilà je j'ai bon espoir qu'on
démarre R3 j'ai pas envie de penser à
une chute encore plus importante
racontez-nous ce dernier mois et demi
que vous avez passé à gérer ce poids si
Football Club beaucoup d'effervescence
une et en même temps ça a été ça a été
un moment
extrêmement enrichissant parce que je me
suis rendu compte que beaucoup de
personnes aimaient ce club
ça a été un moment aussi très
structurant avec l'équipe que j'ai mise
en place où j'ai pu voir un
une dynamique
tellement qui me fait tellement de bien
parce que je me suis pas seul en fait
être dans cette aventure après moi
personnellement
c'était le mois où j'aurais dû être en
vacances j'ai pas eu de vacances le
téléphone a beaucoup sonné mais je le
savais quand j'ai accepté le poste donc
donc je suis dans le dur directement
avec avec je pense un panel de ce que
j'aurai dans l'année c'est-à-dire des
des appels ultra bienveillants de gens
qui me remercient parce que parce que le
club continue grâce au travail de
l'équipe des appels d'autres qui peuvent
être un peu plus véhément parce qu'ils
se retrouvent pas dans la nouvelle
structure alors qu'ils étaient dans
l'autre et ils comprennent pas bien
pourquoi ils sont sortis
des questions liées à l'organigramme que
j'ai mis en place
des fantasmes
réitérer sur qui dirige réellement le
club voilà je pense que je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui va durer encore
pendant deux trois mois et puis très
rapidement à force de à force de
communiquer de parler d'échanger d'être
présent ça va s'arrêter et puis on va
pouvoir se concentrer sur le football
dernière question pourquoi le Poissy
Football Club parce que soit on tenté
une
continuité avec avec un as possible qui
était pas amical mais association
sportive de Poissy qui a été toquée par
la Fédération française soit en tenter
quelque chose comme l'Olympique de
Poissy mais dans le coin s'appelait
l'Olympique c'était pas forcément
bienvenue à 50 mètres du PSG donc du
coup on s'est dit on va rester sobre
donc moi c'est Football Club c'est venu
assez naturellement c'est pas une
décision que j'ai prise seule c'est une
décision qu'on a prise en équipe
nécessairement c'est un parfait il y en
a peut-être d'autres qui auraient voulu
qu'on s'appelle l'un avant de Poissy
autre chose c'est le poids si Football
Club et il va falloir prendre l'habitude
de nous appeler comme ça maintenant
c'est le c'est le PFC des Yvelines voilà
merci Thomas chardon nouveau président
du Poissy Football Club beaucoup de
réussite on vous souhaite beaucoup de
réussite avec ce nouveau club et la
reprise des championnats ce sera en
septembre ici à Poissy
[Musique]